till empty on my friends Silencio Grazia  do you know what brings us here tonight  Oh No okay if it pleases the court all  those who think Eggman is a total  boneheads raise their hands  ramya know greetings wound aneke I am  harz an axe oh I really hurt you know  you big meanie oh it was that stinking  bad face loser get that chopper down  here now I want more men on the road and  sentry guns covering the entrance could  always thought that bouncing was what  Tiggers did best poor boy oh you  remember me you do remember your old  buddy Tigger after all you are Shepherd  we would have shot any other alien out  of the sky but you we give the respect  to our most powerful enemies  wake up to I need you listen to me I  getting in trouble down there you make  every shot count yeah I got this